artificial intelligence divided into two
Fields one of them which marvinsky was
interested in was trying to find out
something about the nature of
intelligence that's science it's
indistinguishable from cognitive science
it just happens to be using different
devices so it's doing it by modeling
with computers instead of modeling on
paper it's basically some cognitive
science that's one part of artificial
intelligence the other part is
engineering trying to construct
something that's useful like say a
Google translate done by Brute Force
absolutely Brute Force no scientific
interest whatsoever
foreign